das ist eine Tageszeitung und früher hat
man da Wohnungsanzeigen gefunden längst
vorbei
heutzutage gibt fast keine Wohnungen
mehr und dafür gibt es jetzt viele
verzweifelte Bauherren er hat es mir
hoch und teilig versprochen der
Verkäufer bei uns kann ist sowas nicht
möglich da zieht ein im Boden weg jetzt
muss ich halt neben der Miete die die
Zinsen zahlen die Kredite weiterbedienen
diese verzweifelten Menschen hatten sich
eine Eigentumswohnung gekauft ein Kredit
aufgenommen Erspartes ausgegeben und
dann hat ihr baunternehmer Insolvenz
angemeldet keine Einzels Schicksale so
wie ihnen geht es tausenden bauen ist
brutal teuer geworden und Deutschland
steckt mitten in einer Baukrise wenn ihr
ein wgzimmer oder eine Wohnung sucht na
dann habt ihr es ja schon selber gemerkt
es gibt kaum was gerade in Städten im
Netz kursieren Videos über Schlangen bei
der Wohnungssuche die Lage ist einfach
mancher Orts dramatisch nur warum zum
Kuckuck bauen wir nicht einfach mehr
Wohnungen hat doch einer immer wieder
versprochen deshalb will ich erreichen
dass wir jedes Jahr Jahr für Jahr
400.000 Wohnung bauen jedes Jahr 400 000
Wohnung zu bauen versprochen gebrochen
warum erkläre ich euch später betrogene
Käufer und auch abgezockte Mieter denn
wenn 500 eine Wohnung wollen dann ist
die Miete ja schnell erhöht vor allendem
hat die Politik lange die Augen
verschlossen warum versagt die Politik
beim Bau und wann findet ihr endlich
wieder eine bezahlbare
[Applaus]
Wohnung
mein Name ist Britta bucholzgarder habe
ich eine interessante speziis Politiker
kennengelernt baupolitische Sprecher der
Partei denn für unsere Sendung Berlin
direkt habe ich mich intensiv mit dem
Kollaps am Bau beschäftigt die
Baubranche Jahrzehnte lang der Stolz in
Ost und West sorgt fast nur noch für
Verdruss wer sich in Berlin wie im Land
umhört der vernimmt fast nur noch Frust
Frust Frust verzweifelt sind auch die
Unternehmer W Wunder wir haben nicht
mehr 1% Zinslage wie noch vor einem Jahr
sondern mittlerweile pro das bedeutet
die gesamte wohnungsbaubranche in
Deutschland hat eine Vollbremsung
hingelegt steht nun vor dieser
Unfallstelle und niemand weiß wie es
weitergeht wir sind auf dem Weg in einer
Rezession und es wird immer noch
angenommen dass wir ein kleines dällchen
bekommen jammern die nur wohl kaum viele
Jahre lief es ja auch Spitze am Bau doch
dann kam der ukrainekrieg und die Lage
hat sich verschärft Baukosten
explodieren teurere Energie und höhere
Zinsen das ist so ein richtig toxischer
Mix die Politik hat jahrelang wenig
getan und jetzt können wir uns aber alle
ganz beruhigt zurücklehnen die Politik
handelt am Montag gab es im Kanzleramt
einen
[Musik]
wohnungsbaugipfel der Gipfel da sollten
gemeinsam Lösungen gefunden werden nur
ausgerechnet drei Tage vorher sagen
diese beiden Herren ab richtig der
Kanzler lädt ein und die gehen nicht hin
die sind aber mächtig wichtig der
Spitzenverband der Wohnungswirtschaft
GdW und der eigentümerverband Haus und
Grund vertreten über ihre Mitglieder
rund 95% des deutschen Wohnungsbestandes
das war schon eine mächtige Ohrfeige für
den Kanzler und die bauministerin
Geiwitz ihr Grund die Regierung hat es
wirklich nicht verstanden und vor dem
Hintergrund haben wir gesagt hier müssen
wir einmal die rote Karte ziehen wir
sagen aber auch ganz deutlich wenn es
darum geht wirklich konstruktiv
miteinander zusammenzuarbeiten dazu sind
wir 247 bereit die Regierung hat es
nicht verstanden wow Absage das habe ich
noch nie gehört also das ist schon
wirklich unglaublich und der Gipfel was
da wohl besprochen und beschlossen wurde
es gab eine Pressekonferenz aber nicht
so wie eigentlich üblich nach dem Gipfel
sondern davor das muss man sich noch mal
genau auf der Zunge zergehen lassen vor
dem eigentlichen Treffen gab es schon
die Pressekonferenz klingt schräg ist es
auch in Wirklichkeit hatten die
Ministerinnen und Minister den Entwurf
schon am Samstag abend abgesegnet also
ganz klar vorher war schon beschlossen
was beschlossen werden soll und dann
wurde zwei Stunden darüber gesprochen
die zwei Herren die ihr eben
kennengelernt habt die hatten mir auch
im Vorgespräch gesagt auf einen
Fototermin oder ein prtermin haben Sie
keine Lust die Reihenfolge wirklich
merkwürdig und dann verkünden Kanzler
und bauministerin ihre Maßnahmen und
lassen keine einzige Frage
zu das heißt Pressekonferenz und im
Grunde ist es nur eine Verkündung nach
dieser Lage was da gerade in der
Baubranche los ist also ganz ehrlich das
ist wirklich dann neben und was kam raus
beim Gipfel was haben Politiker Verbände
Wohnungsunternehmen auf dem Gipfel
gemeinsam beschlossen jetzt seid ihr
wahrscheinlich total überrascht ein
Papier 14 Punkte Maßnahmenpaket heißt
das in der Politik die sollen helfen die
Bauwirtschaft wieder zu beleben ich
stelle euch mal die wichtigsten vor und
dann schreibt ihr mir was ihr davon
haltet okay also beispielsweise soll es
billigere Kredite für familieneben neue
abschreibemöglichkeiten AfA heißt das in
Fachchinesisch und die verpflichtende
Sanierung soll ausgesetzt werden
zufrieden die bundesbauministerin Klara
geiwit schon wir präsentieren Ihnen
heute 14 Maßnahmen die viel verändern
und viel möglich machen na was denkt ihr
mehr Bauförderung bisschen mehr Kredite
und dafür etwas weniger ökologische
Vorschriften bringt es das schreibt es
mir total gerne in die Kommentare und
dabei wäre doch eine Lösung so simpel
mehr Wohnungen
[Musik]
bauen
im Wahlkampf war es das große
Versprechen der SPD jedes Jahr 400.000
Wohnungen zu bauen und damit nicht
aufzuhören 400.000 Wohnungen jährlich
das sollte es sein die Absage von den
beiden Herren vor dem wohngipfel kam
auch aus purem Ärger über diese Zahl das
ist absurde Illusion zu glauben in 2023
werden 400.000 Wohnungen gebaut das nach
dem letzten kanzlergipfel der Kanzler
und die bauministerin sich auf den Rasen
gestellt haben im kanzleram und gesagt
gesagt haben wir werden 20 23 400 000
Wohnungen bauen ich fühlte mich total
veräppelt also gerade Studentinnen
Studenten Köchin Kellner Polizistin
Taxifahrer Verkäufer sie alle suchen in
Großstädten irgendwo nach Wohnung dazu
kommen jetzt auch sehr viele Flüchtlinge
gerade Sozialwohnungen fehlen aber und
wenn wir jetzt mal zusammen auf die
Bauentwicklung der letzten 20 Jahre
schauen dann sehen wir das hier schon
2022 wurde das Ziel deutlich verfehlt
für die Zukunft wird ein ischer Rückgang
vorhergesagt und der Generalsekretär der
SPD Kevin küer was sagt der dazu na hört
mal selber die 400000 das ist die
schlichte Notwendigkeit im Land das wäre
absurd wenn die Politik eine niedrige
Zahl ansetzen würde also wir halten an
diesen Zahlen fest und verstärken unsere
Anstrengung immer weiter bis es klappt
schlichte Notwendigkeit er weiß wir
brauchen diese Zahl er weiß es ist nicht
zu schaffen und nennt trotzdem weiterhin
diese Zahl ist das noch Optimismus oder
schon Realitätsverweigerung bauen ist zu
teuer zu kompliziert und zu viel
Bürokratie zu viele Standard zu wenig
Fachkräfte mir sagte jemand im
Vorgespräch Deutschland habe weltweit
die schärfsten neubaupflichten wer will
denn da überhaupt noch bauen und gibt es
vielleicht auch Signale die die
potenziellen Bauherren auf die Palme
[Musik]
bringen habt ihr denn eigentlich diesen
kreativen Vorschlag gesehen Berliner
singles sollten künftig nur noch ein
Zimmerwohnung bei landeseigenen Wohnung
Baugesellschaften mieten dürfen ist ja
schon eine echt absurde Idee oder ist
jetzt auch schon wieder vom Tisch aber
es zeigt doch nur wie ernst die Lage ist
wo 500 Leute für eine Wohnung anstehen
ist doch auch schnell Betrug am Werke
eine Konsequenz der SPD Fraktion ist
jetzt sie will das Mietrecht verschärfen
mit regeln alles regeln Ende August
haben sie ein Papier verabschiedet ich
habe zufälligerweise hier und das soll
deutlich über die ampelkompromisse
hinausgehen da drin steht z.B
mietenstopp Mietwucher verhindern und
die mietpreisbremse deutschlandweit
ausweiten nur immobilienverbände und
baunternehmen meinen das sei genau das
falsche Zeichen zur falschen Zeit das
ist ihre Sicht der Dinge man muss ja
immer sagen oder sehen dass der Bauherr
von heute der Vermieter von morgen ist
und wenn da weiter an der
mietrechtlichen regulierungsspirale
gedreht wird
wird das nicht dazu beitragen dass
dass der Bauherr heute baut sie saß
übrigens beim Gipfel auch mit am Tisch
und auch die FDP stellt sich naturgemäß
an die Seite der fermeter und schon ist
er wieder da so ein typischer
grundsätzlicher Konflikt zwischen den
ampelparteien Debatten um
mietpreisbremsen sind im Moment wirklich
fehl am Platz wir müssen Signale senden
wie mehr gebaut wird anstatt Signale
dahingehend zu senden wie man Einkommen
von Menschen die bereit sind Geld zu
investieren in den Wohnungsbau
nachhaltig beschneidet schwere Frage wie
seht ihr das gerade jetzt gegen
Mietwucher vorgehen oder würde es das
Bauen noch unattraktiver machen
interessiert mich was was ihr meint also
ich lese alles schreibt es in die
Kommentare und kommen wir doch jetzt mal
zu den möglichen
[Musik]
Lösungsansätzen die Baubranche sieht
noch einen Ausweg weniger klimaregeln
denn seit Jahren werden diese immer mehr
verschärft eh40 kffe 55 kffe 40 was es
da alles gibt die Grünen haben jetzt
gerade notgedrungen sich an einer Stelle
bewegt habbeck der Wirtschaftsminister
verschiebt einen sanierungsstandard aber
beschneiden sie damit nicht ihren
Markenkern Klimaschutz ist das wieder
eine Kröte die sie schlucken müssen
deshalb noch mehr davon einsparen da
sperren sich die Grünen also kein
Lösungsweg eine andere Lösung könnten
mehr private Häuslebauer sein würdet ihr
euch jetzt gerade ein Haus bauen ich
meine wenn ihr es euch leisten könntet
Kanzlerin Merkel hatte 2018 eine Lösung
für ein ähnliches Problem sie versprach
1,5 Millionen neue Wohnungen in 4 Jahren
ihr Weg das baau Kindergeld das gibt es
auch immer noch so eine Art
nachfolgeförderung von gaiwitz doch die
floppt bisher 104 Anträge
deutschlandweit in Hamburg gab es bisher
null Anträge bauen ist vielen Familien
einfach gerade viel zu teuer und
außerdem hat sie so hohe Hürden in
diesem Förderprogramm dass es für kaum
jemanden zutrifft ein anderer Ausweg
nachdem viele schreien ist der stat
könnte doch ein Ausweg sein
[Musik]
oder in Deutschland wurden
jahrzehntelang öffentliche Wohnung
gebaut im Osten staatlich im Westen zu
einem guten Teil auch nach der Wende
aber wurden aber Taus eine öffentliche
Wohnung das sogenannte Tafelsilber
verschärbelt weil der Staat das Geld
brauchte der Bund könnte jetzt wieder
selber Geld in die Hand nehmen und
Wohnung bauen in Düsseldorf sprach mein
Kollege tadeus Parade mit der
öffentlichen Bauplanung darüber die
Städte das Land die öffentliche Hand
braucht gemeinwohlorientierten
Wohnungsbau das kann aber auch über
Genossenschaften über kirchliche Träger
über gemeinwohlträger im Allgemeinen
auch geregelt werden und ich glaube das
sind gute Partner denn die agieren aus
dem Bestand heraus die planen nicht um
zu verkaufen sondern die planen um
größere Bestände zu haben die sie gut
vermieten können das ist ja auch eine
Forderung der Grünen nur viele halten es
für völlig unrealistisch Wolken
kuckucksheim in diesen Zeiten fehlt dem
Bund einfach das Geld gerade war ich bei
im Hintergrund mit Christian Lindner dem
Bundesfinanzminister Hintergründe das
ist so eine Art Gespräch aus dem man
weder schreibt noch zitiert und auf
meine Frage ob mehr Staatsgelder für den
Bau möglich wären kann ich ja jetzt die
Antwort nicht sagen aber ich versuche es
mal mimisch
[Musik]
darzustellen so und jetzt lüfte ich Euch
ein weiteres Geheimnis das keines ist
wie findet ihr wieder eine bezahlbare
Wohnung das war ja doch die Frage warum
ihr überhaupt dran geblieben seid oder
es handelt sich nicht nur um eine
konjunkturelle delle da muss wirklich
viel jetzt bewegt werden keine Delle es
dauert das sagen alle die Ahnung haben
die weit ist wahrscheinlich noch eine
ganz andere wir müssen auch neu denken
pro Kopf wohnen wir heute auf nahe zuu
doppelt so großer Fläche wie 1960 unsere
Eltern oder Großeltern das ist ein
Ansatz Raum anders verteilen und auf dem
Land stehen massenhaft Wohnungen leer
wann findet ihr wieder eine bezahlbare
Wohnung Umdenken oder Glück haben das
jedenfalls wünsche ich Euch und
abonniert gerne unseren Kanal oder baut
ihn mit auf demnächst wieder hier inside
politics